Why didn't you apologize to Chris in your acceptance speech?
I was fogged out by that point.
It's all fuzzy.
I've reached out to Chris...
...and the message that came back is that he's not ready to talk,...
...and when he is, he will reach out.
So, I will say to you, Chris, I apologize to you.
My behavior was unacceptable,...
....and I'm here whenever you're ready to talk.
I want to apologize to Chris's mother.
I saw an interview that Chris's mother did,...
...and you know and that was one of the things...
...about that moment I just didn't realize.
I wasn't thinking but how many people got hurt in that moment?
So, I want to apologize to Chris's mother.
I want to apologize to Chris's family.
I spent the last three months replaying...
...and understanding the nuances...
...and the complexities of what happened in that moment.
And I'm not going to try to unpack all of that right now,...
...but I can say to all of you, there is no part of me...
...that thinks that was the right way to behave in that moment.
There's no part of me that thinks that's the optimal way...
...to handle a feeling of disrespect or insults.